THE STORY ON THE WAR ON
AFGHANISTAN.
FIRST THE OPENING MONOLOGUE WITH
A LOT OF BREAKING NEWS.
THE EVIDENCE OF CORRUPTION AND
BIAS INSIDE OF SPECIAL
COUNSELLOR MUELLER'S TEAM KEEPS
PILING UP.
IT GETS COMPLICATED AND WE'LL
BREAK IT DOWN TO UP.
SARAH CARTER IS NOW TELLING US
THAT THE TOP INVESTIGATOR AND
THE GUY WE TOLD YOU ABOUTAN DREW
WE ISZMANM MET WITH APTO DISCUSS
PAUL MANAFORT.
AND THE NEXT DAY AP- PUBLISHED
A MAJOR EXPOSE ABOUT PAUL
MANAFORT AND SOURCES TELL SARAH
CARTER THAT THEY WERE PROMISING
TO SHARE DOCUMENT AND OTHER
INFORMATION ABOUT MANAFORT WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THERE WILL BE A LOT OF
INFORMATION ON THE ROLE OF THE
MEDIA.
THE A P IS KEMYING IT.
WEISSMAN WENT ON TO JOIN
WEISSMAN NOTIFY OFFED HIS
SUPERIOR ABOUT THE SIT DOWN WITH
THEAP, AND DURING THE TIME HE
DIDN'T HAVE ACCESS TO THE
DOCUMENTS RELATED TO IT.
THAT SHOWS WEISSMANN HAD
PREJUDICE AGAINST PAUL MANAFORT.
ON TOP MUCH HIS TROUBLING
HISTORY.
WISSMANN LED THE OBSTRUCTION
CASE AND ENRON.
HE DESTROYED THAT COMPANY AND
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE LOST
THAT JOB AND THE VERDICT WAS
OVERTURNED WITH A 9- 0 RULING.
WEISSMANN PUT FOUR MARYLAND
EXECUTIVES IN JAIL FOR A YEAR.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE TO QUESTION
THE DECISION OF MAKING ROBERT
MUELLER, WHY WOULD HE MAKE THESE
APPOINTMENTES OF PEOPLE LIKE
WEISSMANN AND ONLY DEMOCRATIC
DONOR.
WHY GIVEN HIS HISTORY WAS HE
APPOINTED AND WHY WOULD MUELLER
FILL THE TEAM TO PEOPLE WHO GAVE
MONEY TO HILLARY CLINTON AND
DNRNGS C AND CANDIDATES LIKE
BARAK OBAMA.
AND A FOLLOW-UP TO OUR EXCLUSIVE
REPORTING LAST NIGHT ON THE
CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
PHONY "FAKE NEWS" RUSSIAN
DOSSIER WITH ALL OF THAT
LITERALLY SURVEY MEMBERS.
CAMPAIGN TEAM OR PRESIDENT-ELECT
DONALD TRUMP AND MEMBERS OF HIS
TEAM.
AND JUST TO GIVE YOU AN IDEA HOW
SERIOUS THIS IS.
A SOURCE IS TELLING ME THIS IS
ALL GOING TO BE PROVEN RIGHT.
HANNITY YOU ARE WAY OVER THE
TARGET AT LOW ALTITUDE AND
EVERYONE ELSE IN THE DETROIT
MEDIA WILL BE PROVEN WRONG ON SO
MANY LEVELS.
YOU CAN'T MACHINING HOW BAD.
AND IN ADDITION TO THE PHONY
DOSSIER, SARAH CARTER REPORTED
AND WE HAVE CONFIRMED THIS
INFORMATION ABOUT SYSTEMIC FISAN
ABUSE WILL BE RELEASED NEXT
WEEK.
THIS IS THE REAL RUSSIA SCANDAL
THAT THE MEDIA NEVER REPORTED ON
AND HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH WHAT
THE "FAKE NEWS" MEDIA HAS BEEN
SPOON FEEDING THE ENTIRE COUNTRY
FOR THE PAST YEAR ABOUT
TRUMP/RUSSIA COLLUSION.
IT DOESN'T EXIST AND TOP
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN TELLING US
AND NO ONE LISTENS AND THEY
REPORT IT ANYWAY.
>> THE RUSSIANS AND THE HACKING
AND DUMPING OF DOCUMENTS IN THE
ELECTION HAD RELATIONSHIPS WITH
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN PEOPLE.
I AM NOT PREPARED TO SAY THERE
IS PROOF TO THE JURY.
>> DO YOU AGREE THAT THERE WAS
NO EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
>> LAST TIME I SPOKE, SENATOR, I
ASKED YOU IF YOU SAW EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION BETWEEN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND THE RUSSIANS AND
>> NO, IT HASN'T.
>> JUST TO BE CLEAR, THERE IS NO
ACTUAL EVIDENCE YET.
>> NO NOT YET.
>> Sean: THE REAL COLLUSION WAS
HILLARY CLINTON AND THE DNC
SPENDING BY FUNDING THE
STALABORS RUSSIAN SOURCE DOSSIER
THAT THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
USED TO SPY ON AN OPPOSITION
PARTY IN A PRESIDENTIAL LEKDZ
YEAR.
AND PRESIDENT TWEETED THIS
CAMPAIGN.
DID FBI USE INTEL TOOL TO
INFLUENCE THE ELECTION?
DID DEMS OR CLINTONS PAY
RUSSIANS AND WHERE ARE THE
HIDDEN AND SMASHED DNC SERVERS
AND WHERE ARE CROOKED HILLARY
EMAILS?
WHAT A MESS.
THE PRESIDENT RAISES
CONSTITUTIONAL QUESTIONS HERE.
WE'LL BREAK IT DOWN AND DISSECT
THE ENTIRE SCANDAL SO THAT
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS IT AND EACH
"FAKE NEWS" CNN UNDERSTAND HOW
SERIOUS IT IS IT.
AND OCTOBER.
THEY PAID FOR THE DOSSIER.
CHRISTOPHER STEELE WAS NOT
INVOLVED AT ALL.
MI SIX AGENT.
AND APRIL OF LAST YEAR, IT WAS
CLEAR THAT TRUMP WOULD BE THE
REPUBLICAN NOMINEE, HILLARY
CLINTON AND THE DNC, THAT DONNA
BRAZIL THAT HILLARY CLINTON
CONTROLLED WITH THE MONEY, TOOK
OVER THE FUNDING OF THE PROJECT.
AND KRISTFARE STEELE DEMOCRATS
ARE PAYING AND HILLARY IS PAYING
AND HE GETS INVOLVED THAT YEAR.
STEELE PAID RUSSIAN SOURCES OVER
THE YEAR AS PART OF HIS QUOTE
JOB.
AND DURING THAT SUMMER STEELE
GOES TO WORK TO PRODUCE WHAT WE
KNOW IS THE PHONY "FAKE NEWS"
DOSSIER THAT INCLUDED FALSE
INFORMATION INCLUDING DONALD
TRUMP IN RUSSIA IN MOSCOW AND
HOOKER AND URINATING ON BEDS.
FORMER FBI JAMES COMEY TESTIFIED
THAT THE CONTENTS OF THE DOSSIER
WERE UNVERIFIED.
THAT DID NOT STOP STEELE FROM
REPORTEDLY BRIEFING NEW'S
OUTLETS LIKE THE NEW YORK TIME
AND WASHINGTON POST, YAHOO NEW
AND NEW YORKER AND "FAKE NEWS"
CNN ALL ABOUT THE DOSSIER.
FOR.
CLINTON WANTED THIS.
AND NOVEMBER 28TH.
CITY HOW IT IS ALL TYING
TOGETHER AND IN JANUARY OF LAST
YEAR, BUZZ FEED DECIDED TO
PUBLISH THE "FAKE NEWS" DOCUMENT
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP'S PERSONAL
TURNING MICHAEL COHENIS SUING
OAF DEFAMATION.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS.
IN THE SUMMER OF 2016, FORMER
CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE, REMEMBER
CARTER PAGE, HE SPIED ON AND
THEY USED THE FISA WARRANT AND
PAUL MANAFORT HE WAS SURVEILLED
BEFORE AND AFTER THE ELECTION.
AND THANKS TO SARAH CARTER AND
AND RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA WAS USED
TO OBTAIN FISA WARPTS TO SPY ON
MEMBERS OF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
AND PRESIDENT-ELECT.
WE ARE LEARNING MORE ABOUT THE
DOSSIER FROM THE GUY WHO CREATED
IT.
SENATOR DIANE FEINSTEIN RELEASED
HIS CONGRESSAM TELL.
FEINSTEIN'S EXCUSE IS LAME AND
UNBELIEVABLE.
TELLING NBC NEWS THAT THE REASON
SHE RELEASED THE INFORMATION AND
EXCHANGE WITH CONGRESS, SHE HAD
A BAD COLD.
AND THE DOG ATE MY HOMEWORK AND
THAT SLOWED DOWN HER MENTAL
ABILITYINGLY.
FEINSTEIN DID A MAJOR BREACH OF
TRUST AND PROVIDED REVEALING
INFORMATION.
GLENN STIM SIM, FUSION GPS.
HE NEVER BOTHERED TO VERIFY.
WHAT?
NOT EVEN BOTHERED TO VERIFY WHAT
STEELE BROUGHT HIM FROM THE
RUSSIAN SOURCE AND HE WAS
AGAINST TRUMP IN THE ELECTION.
SIMPSON MET WITH THE RUSSIAN
LAWYER BEFORE AND AFTER THE
MEETING AT TRUMP TOWER.
REMEMBER THE ONE WITH DON JUNIOR
GLENN SIMPSON WHO HATES TRUMP
AND NEVER VERIFIED THE DOSSIER
IT IS IT A MERE COINCIDENCE THAT
HE MET WITH THE RUSSIANS.
AND HE MET WITH WITHDREWS
O'VE -- BRUCE ORH.
HIS WIFE NELLY WORKED FOR FUSION
CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID FOR THE
PHONY DOSZIER AND LIE AND PROP
GRANDA.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
POLITICALIZED AND WEAPONIZED THE
POUFRFUL TOOLS FOR OUR
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY AND USED
THEM TO GO AFTER THE OPPOSITION.
CLINTON PUTTING THE FIX IN.
BERNIE SANDERS AND DONNA BRAZIL.
THE FIX WAS IN.
BERNIE HAD NO SHOT.
THE FIX WAS ALSO IN.
THINK ABOUT THIS WITH THE
CLINTONS, EXRONERATION.
REMEMBER COMB EP AND PREERT THEY
DIDN'T INVESTIGATE YET BUT
WRITING THEULARIES.
AND HE USED THE DOSSIER TO FIX
THE GENERAL ELECTION.
BEING EXPOSED IS MASSES ABUSES
OF OUR CONSTITUTIONAL AND STIFF
OF OUR CONSTITUTIONAL AND STIF
OF OUR CONSTITUTIONAL AND CIIF
OF OUR CONSTITUTIONAL AND CIVI
REACHING A POINT THAT YOU CAN'T
EVEN IMAGINE.
TOP OFFICIALS IN THE HIGHEST